hey everyone this is jeremy schiefling
with khan academy
thank you so much for joining us today
i'm super excited
for a really action-packed session today
and i think this is a very timely
session as well
as we head into the last month of an
incredibly tough year i think one of the
things that 2020 has taught us
is even in this moment of social
isolation
how much we need each other how much we
need partners and collaborators in our
lives
and that's why i'm so grateful in this
moment of gratitude
for our partners at headspace because as
much as we at khan academy love to focus
on
academics and scholastic development
we also know this year is about that
more holistic idea of serving your
students
how do you make sure that their social
emotional needs are met
as well as your own as educators and so
that's why i'm thrilled to introduce you
to two rockstar presenters from
headspace first we have sam snowden
who's a mindfulness facilitator
who specializes in supporting students
and teachers so has worked with tons of
folks exactly like yourselves
for years at this point and has actually
worked directly with elementary schools
with principals with educators across
the world
and she's joined by alice matthew who's
the head of social impact at headspace
and what she does there is a larger
portfolio that also includes headspace
for educators
which is an amazing program if you
haven't checked it out already which
basically gets you all the power of head
skates for free
just for doing the great work that you
do as an educator and alice we'll share
more about that in a little bit
in the meantime before we dive in i want
to answer uh sort of three housekeeping
questions that typically come up
number one in true webinar fashion yes
the session will be recorded and you
will get a copy of it
automatically in your inbox right after
the session
number two as educators ourselves we
want to make this super interactive
so ask questions at any point using the
questions tab on your go to webinar
control panel
and also join lots of our pop quizzes
that sam will be sending your way
throughout
and then third and finally i know a lot
of you are interested in the headspace
swag bag
so free access to the headspace platform
for friends and family
as well as a copy of their best-selling
book on mindfulness
just for being here live with us today
you are automatically entered into a
drawing for one of those five swag bags
we will notify you after the session if
you're one of those lucky winners
so that being said thank you all again
for making time
and investing in today's session with us
and with that being said i want to turn
it over to sam and alice
well what an introduction thank you so
much jeremy
and uh thank you khan academy you know
for this opportunity to talk to you all
hello welcome um congratulations for
making this time for yourself
um as jeremy said i'm alison athoon i
run
headspace for educators um as a parent
you know this has been
such a hard year and i can only imagine
for you all as educators
renewed respect for the jobs that you do
the incredible job you do and
how challenging it's been this year for
you i'm sure
so i'm really excited to introduce sam
um i'm i have to say my meetings with
sam are my favorite part of the day
there's just something about her that
just is instantly relaxing
um so i'm so excited we get to spend
this half an hour together um
but first we thought we'd just before i
sort of introduced sam just to give you
a little idea of what we're going to
cover today
as jeremy said we want this to be really
practical i mean what we say at
headspace is meditation made simple and
that's what we've thought about for
today what are some simple
exercises for you to use for yourself
and for your students
so sam's going to talk a bit about what
mindfulness is
don't worry if you've got if you have a
lot of experience or you have no
experience at all
um hopefully something for everyone here
and
really then how it can help you optimize
your learning environment
um both remotely and hopefully back in
the classroom too
and then we'll finish off with some q a
so i'm so excited to introduce samantha
um
jeremy did a wonderful introduction you
know we're really excited to work with
her
um on headspace for educators she's an
amazing human being um so welcome
my friends and colleagues martha thank
you so much alice
i feel completely overwhelmed with love
and it's a great way to start
and um i just want to thank all of you
all the teachers for showing up and
caring about you know bettering of your
teaching practice
and um i'm also i've also been a teacher
in the classroom so i know the struggle
i've been a substitute teacher which is
kind of the hardest
gig i think um so all of the
the things that i'll be offering you
definitely come from a place of embodied
experience i've tried them out
of their tried and true methods um
for bringing mindfulness into your own
life and also into your
students lives so i'm just so grateful
to be here and i'm so grateful to to all
of you for all the hard work you're
doing
so i wanted us to start out actually
with a practice
um we'll be doing a couple practices
together
and the reason for that is that when you
embody the practice
when you do it yourself um you have a
better idea
of how to lead it with your with your
students
and so i want to just preface that
with um if you want to keep your eyes
open
the whole time i'm going to invite you
to keep your eyes closed but if you want
to keep them open you can just
rest your attention on a spot in front
of you a few
inches or a few feet in front of you and
just let your eyelids kind of rest
halfway closed
and the first practice we're going to be
doing is working with anchors
and when i talk about anchors with my
students i often show them
this little bell and i talk about how
anchors
keep a boat right from drifting too far
away
so if this is our anchor and our boat
wants to follow the waves or if this is
like our mind and our mind wants to
follow different streams of thought
the anchor brings it back and it brings
it back again
and again and again and over time we get
much better at paying attention
we get more control over our attention
so that it doesn't feel like
it is being taken away from us but we
have some
some mastery over it so this is really a
foundational practice that you can do
with your students
um we're going to do a three minute
around a three minute practice but you
can even shorten it
to a one-minute practice with your
students
so if you're ready i don't know you
maybe you're driving in a car or if it's
not safe to do a practice please
you know just listen and participate
that way
but if you are in a semi-private space
and you feel comfortable
you can join along with me so the first
thing we start with is our body posture
so you want to have your feet flat on
the floor and you just want to bring
some length to your spine
i like to tell the kids to imagine that
someone has a string
right at the top of their head and
they're just gently pulling that string
and it's
lengthening the spine
and then when you're ready you can close
your eyes
and i like to start with just a little
bit of squeezing and
releasing we call this progressive
muscle relaxation just to help you get
into your body
so let's just start with our shoulders
just bringing your shoulders up toward
your ears
and giving a little squeeze
and hold this for just a few seconds
and then take a nice deep breath in
through your nose
and as you exhale just let the shoulders
relax down away from your ears
and so we've all arrived hopefully in
this still
posture and
as we're sitting still for maybe the
first time today
we might notice our mind is so busy
so we're going to bring just a natural
curiosity
to notice what our body feels like in
this moment
are our eyelids fluttering does our
heart beat
racing or is it really slow do we feel
sleepy
so just notice
and then you're just going to start to
take a couple deep breaths
feeling your belly go out and in as you
breathe
so let's breathe in through our nose
and out through our nose
you can think of the words breathing in
breathing out and then imagine it as a
whisper
breathing in
breathing out
and now just hear it as a whisper in
your mind
and see if you can let go of any control
over your breathing so that your breath
is just natural you don't have to
remember to breathe or try to breathe
breathing will just happen on its own
we're just greeting our breath staying
with the feeling or the sensation
of the belly going out and in
and if your mind starts to drift away
just like the boat
drifting away on the waves just label
your thinking as thinking or planning
or maybe noticing sounds
and then very gently very kindly come
back to the words breathing
in breathing out and the sensations in
your belly as you breathe
before we end our practice see if
there's one thing that you notice
today about your breath that you never
noticed before
when you're ready you can slowly open
your eyes
coming back to our space together
and i'm just curious maybe in the chat
you can
mention one thing that you noticed
you might have noticed i notice usually
if i'm
amped up and i have a lot of energy that
my eyelids are fluttering
or that my heart is beating so it's very
somatic it's very body driven if
i'm amped up but if i'm sleepy i might
notice
heaviness in my eyes i might notice um
you know dreams of falling asleep or you
know cravings to to get in my bed and
sleep
so it's different what we're noticing is
um different each depending on how we're
feeling
so if you'd like to share something that
you've noticed
uh from this practice you can go ahead
and share in the chat
a lot of folks are really sort of
getting into this um
deanna mentions tension in her neck kim
says i noticed my head hurt a little bit
um emily noticed here we are in december
and i have a stuffy nose
so definitely a lot of sense of
heaviness and weariness at this point of
the year
thank you guys for sharing that too and
so anything you're noticing
whether it's pleasant unpleasant or
neutral
is practicing mindfulness that's that's
the muscle that we're trying to flex
with ourselves and with our students so
that's a that's really good noticing and
they're things that if you think about
the categories of things we can pay
attention to
the the one that we all mentioned in
this practice was sensation
right that's a huge category our
internal body sensations
um another category is mental activity
so things that we're feeling
um things that we're thinking about or
urges that we're having or even
images that arise in our mind right like
flashes of memories from the day
um another category is our five senses
so we might be
when we close our eyes like we just did
we might notice wind
i noticed the heater in my house so it's
nice and toasty
and warm for my skin or you might notice
smells if you have a candle or any
scents in the house
so that's another category and the final
category
of things we pay attention to has to do
with our relationships
so you might have had a memory of
someone
that you love that's in your house
that's you know that you just thought oh
i really like that person or
what i wonder how they're doing or i
hope they're well um so any
any of these um it's this any of the
stimuli from these different categories
can pop
up during our practice and when we're
being mindful
we're just noticing them with this kind
of curiosity and this openness
to experience so this is great
and well when you're thinking about
how to bring this into your classroom or
how to practice it with your students
you can teach them about anchoring just
like i taught you
and then you can set a timer for one
minute so once they know how to feel
their breath
notice sensations in their body and
think of the words breathing in and
breathing out
they can practice in silence and you
might start with
30 seconds if they're really young
children and then
work up and progress to longer periods
of time
or you can just keep it at a minute
that's sufficient for a lot of students
in a lot of different age groups
so that's one practice um the second
practice i want to
talk to you a little bit about is the
stop practice and this one
i've talked to many many children and i
think this is their favorite
because it's an acronym first of all so
they can remember
the steps and what to do and it's
helpful because the way we're going to
practice it now and how you can practice
it in your classroom
is to ring a bell randomly or any kind
of sound you can
you know program your phone to go off at
different times during the class
and then when you hear the sound you're
going to practice these four steps
so the four steps we'll just do them
kind of
briefly together we stop what we're
doing
and that's actually one of the hardest
things to do right is to stop ourselves
from
continuing to ruminate or continuing to
believe a thought pattern that we're
having
so we stop we take a deep breath and we
can do this again with our eyes closed
so let's take a deep breath together
and then we just observe and for this
activity i'm going to have us observe
one thing in each of our senses
so let's start by observing a sound just
listening to a sound we can hear
let's notice a smell a scent
let's notice a taste in our mouths or
just um
anything we notice if we run our tongue
across our teeth
let's notice the feeling of our our
clothes against our skin
so the insulation of our shirts or our
sweaters
and just the feeling of being supported
by whatever surface you're on the weight
of your body
and finally as we open our eyes just
look around you
and notice something beautiful or
something that you're grateful for
something that you're really glad you
have in your personal space
great so that's that's the stop practice
and
as far as observing you can have your st
you can prompt your students to observe
their five senses like we just did
or you can just have them observe
whatever they're noticing in their mind
a thought a feeling a sensation so it's
up to you
depending on what's going on in the room
or in the class
so whenever i'm going to read ring the
bell twice during our presentation it'll
sound like this
and i'm going to do it randomly when
when you don't expect it and we're going
to do the stop practice
so i'll just say each word and we'll
practice together
i just wanted to share a quick story
about the stop practice
i had a student who was about eight
years old and i taught him
the stop practice and then the next
session the parents came
and his mom raised raised her hand and
said
i really want to thank you for teaching
my child this this practice
and she said that um when they had lost
their dog their dog had run away
the mom was getting frantic and panicky
and she said her son said mom let's stop
let's take a breath let's observe the
sensation
and then let's proceed with more calm
and he led her through it
and she said it made such a difference
so we never know
you know when we're teaching our
students how this is impacting their
families and how they're internalizing
they often um don't aren't very emphatic
or um they're not gushing about the
experiences they're
they're having or learning but then when
you hear stories like this it's very
inspiring and
motivates you to keep going
so i wanted to talk a little bit about
what meditation is
and arts our expectations versus the
reality
so if i'm not sure we're going to do a
little poll to see what your
meditation background is so i don't know
if many of you have practiced before or
not
but when you first start to practice
many people
get really turned off get turned away by
the fact that
when you close your eyes you're
bombarded with thoughts
you're bombarded with the busyness and
the rush
of of your um of your mind
and so a lot of people will just give up
at that point and say
this isn't what i expected because
there's an expectation that we'll get
calm
that our thoughts will start to slow
down when we want them to
um but the reality is that we're facing
the busyness that rush
that that speed of thought that reflects
the speed of our lives
so what we're really doing what we're
trying to cultivate
is a sense of um openness
and a willingness to be with things as
they are so we're sitting with
whatever shows up in our practice and
that's why we set a timer
because if we did this indefinitely it
would be unsustainable
but we set a timer for you know five if
we're adults five to twenty minutes
and um and we see what shows up and we
that
that willingness to be with things as
they are changes the relationship we
have to our
internal world and it becomes a lot more
peaceful a lot more manageable to
confront
our worries our thoughts our projections
and it prevents us from ruminating we
catch ourselves in the middle of the day
in the middle of our lives when our
mind starts to ruminate or starts to
overthink
we don't want to discourage thinking of
course but overthinking
can be problematic so that's
a little bit about how our expectations
really match up with
with the reality of meditation and
mindfulness
so here's a great poll what is your
family familiarity with mindfulness are
you new to it have you tried it a couple
times
or do you have a regular practice and um
oh i can't vote sorry about that
no that's okay the answers are coming in
fast and furious though back half of
the more than 400 teachers across the
country have now voted
and we'll close it in about five seconds
cool
and it looks like as you can see here on
the screen
um a lot of folks have dabbled with it
but also a lot of newbies as well
nice okay great so about half have
tried it a few times and a quarter of
you have a regular practice so that's
you know exactly what i'm talking about
um and if we were together and we could
have a dialogue
i would ask you what helps you sustain
that regular practice what keeps you
coming back
i know for a lot of people if we
struggle i myself have struggled with
anxiety
so mindfulness was the it was just an
amazing tool for my life and never
thought i would teach it but i
started practicing at 15 and never
stopped so
it's an incredible tool and you all have
your own reasons for being drawn to it
or for
continuing to practice it
awesome
so we can go to the next slide
so lino if you wouldn't mind um sharing
your screen once more sorry about that
let's switch back from the pull
there we go ah perfect
thanks everyone for those great answers
keep them coming i'm gonna just
[Music]
so we'll stop take a breath
and this time observe a sensation in
your body
maybe your hands or your face
and then we'll proceed nice
so what is mindfulness um to those of
you that
have not tried it before or maybe only
once or twice
mindfulness is this way of being that we
actually naturally
have it's a propensity we have we don't
have to learn it like we would need to
learn math
um but it's it's often um
not accessible because we're so busy
or it's very hard to cultivate uh deeply
because
um it's like for the reasons i mentioned
that there's this little learning curve
we have to get over
to to really rest in that in the
practice
so a quick definition of it is that it's
our bill
our ability to be present and attentive
with openness curiosity and a kind mind
so building that relationship of
kindness and openness to our experiences
and uh being willing like i said before
being willing to show up
however you are right like showing up to
yourself
and witnessing what's coming up however
it shows up so there's a lot
of acceptance and when we accept what's
happening we're not rejecting it
because the rejection is what causes us
a lot of stress
trying to change trying to get to a
certain mindset that we want to get to
can produce kind of this inner conflict
that becomes
unsustainable and kind of zaps us of our
energy
all right so why do we practice
mindfulness
um i think when i think of teaching in
the classroom i think of these moments
i've had where
i've become a different person um
especially with students in
classrooms where there was just no
interest when i was a substitute teacher
and people expected to um have a day off
and i would get so agitated and so upset
and if i didn't have my mindfulness
skills i think i would have turned into
someone that i didn't even recognize
i would have probably you know screamed
or hit a table
or something really really drastic
because it's so there's so many moments
where there's frustration
um but if we think about using it as a
stress management tool in the classroom
we're stopping to notice we're taking a
moment to notice
what's going on within us and just the
acknowledgment
of that sensation that thought that
emotion
helps it to settle just the pure
acknowledgement of it we don't have to
do anything more than that most of the
time
and that allows us to stay resilient and
to
to meet our students with more calm and
to meet them with more bandwidth
which makes the teaching profession a
sustainable one instead of a
you know one where you get burnt out in
the course of a year or two
it also helps our physical health so it
increases our immune system
it strengthens our immune system um it's
correlated with longevity
and that has to do with telomeres which
are the little strands at the end of
um these little like frills at the end
of our dna strands that deteriorate over
time
so studies have shown that it preserves
it keeps those
telomeres intact for longer periods of
time
and it also helps prevent cardiovascular
disease
and inflammation in our body so it has
tremendous health benefits
not to mention sleep duration and
quality of sleep
and then for our students it's giving
them this tool to focus
and to be able to regulate their
attention so that
when they feel their attention drifting
away they have a strategy
i often ask children i work with who's
ever told you to pay attention raise
your hand
and then my follow-up question is who's
ever taught you how to pay attention
and there are no hands right because
it's something that we if we're not
taught we don't
really know how to do some of us are
naturally better at it and some most of
us i can say are not great
at it and it's also a tool for emotional
regulation
so when we notice an emotion that we're
having and we're able to discern it
right we're able to finally discern
between frustration and anger for
example or
worry and regret when we give kids
this vocabulary to explain or name or
label how they're feeling
again that the intensity comes down and
they stay in that zone of resilience
which allows them to bounce back and and
actually resume
learning because learning will
temporarily pause
or stop if the emotion is too intense
okay so we can go to the next slide
so here's another poll for us in a few
words what is one of the biggest
challenges you experience
as an educator
and i just think of so many so let's see
what we have here
burnt out students not showing up that's
a big one right now
um keeping students motivated grappling
with technology
and students struggling academically or
emotionally
and this one educators can actually
choose as many as apply
and we're seeing actually quite a few
choosing the burnout which is certainly
um topical tonight um the motivation
piece which also fits in with what we're
talking about
and the struggles probably academically
and emotionally so
yeah definitely all things that we can
address with some of these mindfulness
practices
yes okay so the biggest ones here are
the motivation component and then the
struggle the academic or emotional
struggle
absolutely and a lot of students right
now
i know a lot of high school students are
finding because
friendships are so important in their
lives at that developmental period
that having restricted access to their
friend groups is
is causing depression um in a lot of
them and also just this like what is
what is life even for anymore what is
you know like these existential
issues that are coming up so um yeah
and i think when when we're thinking
about how to address that from a
mindfulness perspective
i think of the word compassion you know
just
witnessing when a student's sharing um
something like that with us just just
being the source of witness
and being the source of containment for
their
emotional experience and and relating to
it letting them know that they're not
alone that this is part of the human
experience and that a lot of
students are feeling this way too and
then um
if we had more time maybe we'll have
this practice in our
headspace for educators group on
facebook but there are practices that
help you build resiliency and help build
um a feeling of connection and joy
and ease when in the midst of these
difficult emotions
and sam i know that um some of the folks
from the very first exercise we did
said they had their dinner in the oven
the ratatouille was cooking in some
cases
do you want to finish up with a final
exercise or should we go into some q a
at this point what do you think is the
best
i think we should go into some q a i
want to give everyone a chance to
ask questions i know we're at the we're
at our end time so
yeah please feel free to ask any
questions and i'm
happy to address them and the stuff we
didn't get to again that we have this
headspace for educators group on
facebook and we're going to
be featuring these techniques on that
page so
you can join and take part and um
so that you won't miss any of the this
last exercise that we didn't get to on
compassionate breathing
very cool and alice before we dive into
the q a and of course people should feel
free to ask questions via the questions
tab at any point
did you want to call out anything around
headspace for educators and how they
access that
yeah i mean we've got the information
here and as sam said um
we'll be sharing exercises every week in
the facebook group
which is called headspace for educators
um yeah and i just encourage if anyone
wants to sign up they can just go to our
headspace.com
uh landing page forward slash educators
and all the information is there
so uh yeah we're we're just uh excited
to be able to share these practices
today but
also welcome you to come back and check
out more through the facebook group
that's awesome again like super generous
in any year but especially pertinent in
this one so thank you all for
sharing that so broadly across the world
um lots of questions are coming in
and so i want to start with one that
kelly had asked at the very beginning of
the session sam
which is all this is awesome in a
teacher-led way
she can really imagine using it with her
students but are there practices that
you can help your students with to do on
their own
so they sort of take that learning and
make it part of their own practice even
when the teacher is not there
absolutely that's such a good question
and i think i would say to start with
anchoring
so to encourage them to set a timer for
one minute after you teach them
the the exercise we did in the beginning
using an anchor word like
words like breathing in breathing out
noting what they're feeling coming back
to their anchor
just that simple practice is going to
help them develop mindfulness
as a trait as a as a kind of default way
of relating to their internal
experiences
so if there was one i would point out i
would say that one
um another one that will feature on the
the facebook group
is to um is loving kindness practice or
if your children are younger you can
call them friendly wishes
and that involves thinking about someone
that you find easy
to like or love a friend or a loved one
and wishing them happiness wishing them
peace and wishing them health and
there's a
there's a practice for that and and um
and recordings so that you can they can
practice it on their own
we also have a lot of material like that
on the app so
kids can access it themselves and and
just press play and and be guided
through those exercises but i would say
um
the anchoring practice and friendly
wishes are two really good
practices that kids but once they learn
them they do say that they practice them
on their own
that's awesome yeah i'm so jealous in
retrospect that i didn't learn this when
i was at that age because i feel like it
would be such a foundation for a great
life
um you know sort of a companion question
very much speaking to the reality of
2020
carol says if a student wants to
practice at home
for right now home is so chaotic so
noisy
with all the distractions that are
facing us digitally do you have any
practical recommendations for how
students can find that space in their
home lives
to really invest in this practice
absolutely
yes so i mean one one way it might be
really cold wherever you're
wherever you are so outside might not be
accessible
but if it is you know going outside and
just starting the day with five senses
um just i i did this myself like i'll
sit on my stairs outside and i close my
eyes i feel the sun on my face
i take in a deep breath and i just tap
into each one of my five senses
and end with gratitude i just say i ask
myself what's one thing i'm grateful for
so that's a very easy accessible
practice for them to do
and i think what i'm speaking to is the
fact that
it's important to emphasize to students
that one minute
is enough you know even if they're it's
a reset button
and it's a way of setting the tone for
your day so
they don't need to carve out large
periods of time or find
you know an hour of quiet somewhere in
their house they can just find
a little spot you know maybe even in
their bed
just sitting upright in their bed before
they get up and start the rest of their
day
to do one minute of breathing with a
timer on their phone
or even lying down before they fall
asleep a lot of kids
use um the app and and guided meditation
just to fall asleep
because their minds are so busy at the
end of the day that it's incredibly
difficult
so those are some recommendations i
think most most kids have a bed
of their own and and um that's like a
sacred space for
them so encouraging them to do practices
in the morning or
before they fall asleep can be really
helpful for that i love that and i think
that'll resonate
go ahead go ahead alice my apologies i
was just going to add it to such a great
suggestion we see the sleep cast being
used a lot
by young people and i think if obviously
the app is free for teachers
if any of your students want to access
the content there's a lot of free
content on youtube as well as on the
website which we've made
available to everyone this year
especially since kobit hits so
there's plenty of free resources there
as well um even if they don't have
access to the full app so i'd encourage
them to go to go to those
other channels too that's awesome
okay so the next couple of questions are
about some of the resistance that
educators have got in
trying to bring mindfulness into the
classroom in the past mary and others
have referred to the parental resistance
which sometimes is based in a religious
sort of objection of hey
doesn't this sort of go against my own
spiritual beliefs is there a conflict
there
have you heard any kind of complaints
about that from parents that you've
worked with
and how can an educator do that delicate
dance
such a great question yes actually um
when i first started teaching it i was
just in schools
i was working for non-profits and i was
in schools and i would just do it
on the fly i would say okay i see that
these kids need emotional regulation
skills so i'm just going to
do it and one time i had a parent
withdrawal her child from my
group because of what you just said um
these religious reasons
she was worried that it was conflicting
uh with her religion
and it brought up a lot of fear for her
at the time i didn't really know what to
do i was in my early 20s and
i was very surprised that that it was
being viewed that way
but over time i started to realize how
how it can be
viewed in um in a threatening way like
this is conflicting with my religious
practice and a lot of religious
practices have their own contemplative
um format right through prayer
or in in other ways so
what i would do now i mean if you do if
you can talk to
parents invite them to participate
um in in the practice and kind of see it
as a new experience with curiosity
um let them know that it's not a
religion that there's
a lot of and you might even provide them
with the scientific
research that you can find really easily
i mean all it's all over the internet
um but bringing it back to the brain you
know bringing it back to the
neuroscience and
how this is helping their child with
attention and focus and how secular it
is
um and that it actually
i've told some people i've worked with
who are you know devout devoutly
christian or devoutly jewish that
these practices can actually enhance
your connection to your religion
they can actually help you go deeper
into prayer or
or connect with readings or teachings
that you find so
deeply meaningful in your life um so
those are just some suggestions of
bridging that gap you know time
bringing in the science inviting them to
practice
with you with and with their child and
um encouraging them to use it as a tool
and also reminding them that it's part
of our it's a it's a natural capacity we
all have
we're just strengthening that capacity
with practice
i love that well said and um i think the
sort of flip
side to that question is from the
student perspective i remember when i
was a teacher
i would get lots of questions like mr s
why do we have to learn this why does
this matter
i can certainly imagine students asking
those questions about mindfulness
maybe if they're younger and they don't
quite understand the neuroscience
implications
what could you tell a student to get
them really excited about this practice
yeah so it depends on their age um with
kids
who are younger they just want to play
so you can do
more movement there's a lot of like you
know drumming
or playing a song like freeze dance a
lot of classic games that we were taught
as kids
work really well as a mindfulness
teaching tool
like red light green light or um
uh what's the other one oh simon says i
use a lot and then we play
simon says and then we talk about
attention and then i usually use the
bell
so i'm not even really talking about the
benefits with the kit with little little
ones i'm just kind of
inviting them to play and while we're
playing
i'm talking a little bit about attention
and about um
dealing with hard feelings uh with older
kids
i sometimes i'll read a list with their
eyes closed i'll have i'll read a list
of emotions like anger fear
embarrassment
judgment um and i'll ask them to just
notice what happens as they hear those
feelings and some are positive some are
difficult feelings
and then when they open their eyes i'll
ask them what they noticed how many of
you had all those feelings at some point
in your life
or how many of you like what feeling
really stuck out to you when i was
reading that list
and this is a jumping off point to have
a conversation about how
mindfulness helps us deal with these
incredibly big
emotions that are arising in adolescence
um i sometimes even tell teens that like
a little bit about what's going on in
their brain at this
at that age where their dopamine their
brain is
is a lot more susceptible to the effects
of dopamine so their highs are higher
their lows are lower
than adults over 26. and
um just knowing empowering them with
that knowledge i find so important
you know as teens we had health class
mine was not great
i don't think i remember like really
retained anything
but we we feel this responsibility as
teachers and adults to
educate students about their brain about
their body but i think the brain
is regarding when it when it pertains to
emotional regulation largely gets
neglected
um so i would say empower them with that
knowledge
and um and also come back to the emotion
and come back to the um just a lot of
students can relate to the
difficulty in handling difficult
emotions and they'll they'll find
a purpose and a connection to the
practice as it helps them in that regard
awesome and i know that ratatouille is
getting very crisp in the oven so let me
finish up with one final very 20 20
question
yeah which of course is kimberly asking
any tips for
implementing all this effectively
especially in a remote or online
learning environment
i can imagine how challenging and new
this might feel even in person
but with this extra barrier between
myself and my students
how do i cross that divide and really
make this land
that's a great question so actually that
was on one of our slides that we didn't
get to but
it's important to have a ritual so that
kids expect
okay fridays we're going to do a minute
of mindfulness or
mindful mondays so that you have
something realistic
and you don't want to kind of overwhelm
yourself with every day we're going to
do a practice and then you're stressing
out to find
you know new and interesting material
every day so i would say start out small
so that it's realistic for you
have a little plan in place so that you
know what you're doing what your plan is
for the week and um and then you can use
resources
again on the app we have or even on
youtube you can just
type in headspace and you'll get these
great videos
you can go through the videos and choose
ones that you like
that resonate with you and then use it
as like maybe carve out 10 minutes
in your class time online watch the
video together and then
have your students be able to share what
came up for them while they watch the
video
what resonated with them um so then it's
already pre-prepared for you
that that lesson in that theme and you
don't feel like you have to create more
material and more stress
on you for that because that's i think
all of us
just none of us need that right so we
want it to be fun
we want it to be a relief for us too
that when we show that video or when we
uh offer a practice that it's something
we need as well it bridges
this this gap between adults and and
children adults
or teacher and student and it helps
bring us together as we realize we all
need this pause we
all need um this this ritual
in our in our week wow
i love that and i think i'll actually
give danielle the last
word here she says thank you so much for
your time and creating this lovely space
i can't wait to you stop with my
students and i saw so many other
comments like that
throughout the session so i know there's
going to be a lot of more mindful
classrooms than students and
educators starting tomorrow morning so
on behalf
of the entire khan community i want to
thank the full head space team sam alice
leno has been running the slides behind
the scenes
making this possible um thank you for
the swag bags which we'll announce after
this
and thank you for head space for
educators which as you mentioned is free
at headspace.com
educators um one last little request of
all the audience members before we go
back to our ratatouille
is you will get a three question survey
that pops up right after the session
please let us know what you thought what
was useful and if you'd like to have
headspace come back and do other
sessions let us know as well
because we can always use that for
future programming that being said
a huge thank you to everyone for
investing your scarce time with us
tonight
hope it was well worth your while and
thank you sam alice and leno
for sharing your expertise and your
wisdom across the country
thank you all so much thank you jeremy
thank you jeremy later